another loss felt across the country
today former raiders head coach john
madden he died this morning at 85 years
of age ron futrell taking a look back at
the life and times of a man who was much
more than just a winning football coach
to me this is where it all starts you
see the you know seven man sled it's the
greatest game in the world hitting a
seven-minute sled that's the first thing
they do so that would
get rid of all hangovers
john madden was the legendary hall of
fame coach for the raiders it was madden
who instilled a raiders history of
winning and winning big in 10 seasons
with the raiders he made the playoffs
eight times and led the raiders to their
first super bowl win in 1976.
he was only 32 years old when al davis
made him head coach of the silver and
black
hall of famer art shell played for
madden for nine seasons he was a great
great coach he understood people
and that was his that that to me was his
biggest asset
he could understand each and every
single football player on that football
team
and he understood what made each one of
us tick
he knew how to get to us
when his football career ended madden
went into the broadcast booth spent 30
years with cbs calling football games
what's the old body slam you know what
they're doing wrestling
he was a star of tv commercials and who
doesn't know the football video game
that bears his name
john madden was a family man who didn't
like to fly and drove a bus to and from
games a heartbreaking loss for the
raiders and for the entire nfl
ron futral reporting live local now
to honor madden staff at allegion
stadium put his photo up on the marquis
owner mark davis also lit the torch at
the venue tonight that happened at 6 p.m
honoring john madden at the original
kickoff time for monday night football
current and former raiders players
speaking out about the news quarterback
derek carr saying he is thinking of
madden's family defensive end max crosby
weighing in simply saying rest in peace
also former raider jerry rice tweeting
information calling baden a legend who
was loved by all saying that he will be
missed denise